as the public feud between kim
kardashian and her estranged husband
kanye west rages on a source tells et
that the 44 year old rapper wants a more
formal custody agreement with the
reality star i'm just extremely happy
can you tell by my face
of course the 41 year old kkw beauty
founder filed for divorce after six
years of marriage back in february 2021
and asked for joint legal and physical
custody of their four children north
saint chicago and psalm a source at the
time told et that the rapper was fine
with the joint custody agreement and the
two were committed to co-parenting
together we are so blessed to have the
best support system and the best family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through but now
seems like things may change et source
explains that the two currently don't
have a formal agreement in place kim has
the kids and kanye is allowed to see
them whenever he wants within reason but
according to the source yay feels like
he hasn't been getting enough time with
his little ones and if his lawyer can't
work something out with kim he'll go to
court we have to thank kim
of course this all comes after the
grammy winner posted this snap of his
eight-year-old daughter north's backpack
to instagram that's a pin of him kim and
an alien which he captioned quote this
was on my daughter's backpack when i was
allowed to see her last week this is why
i go so hard for my family i am wired to
protect my family at all costs he
concluded his message writing don't
worry northie god is still alive
shortly after that kim who has seemingly
tried to keep their issues private
swooped into the comments to ask her ex
to cool it quote please stop with this
narrative you were just here this
morning picking up the kids for school i
think you have to have a sense of humor
and while their custody agreement is
still tbd
one thing the court has decided is kim's
marital status yup earlier this month a
judge granted her petition to be
declared legally single while she
continues to work out a divorce
settlement with the musician at the end
of the day life is about being happy
now things are getting more serious
between the skim's founder and her
boyfriend saturday night live star pete
davidson who has been the target of many
of kanye's online attacks
god send me from that crash just so i
could beat pete davis
and over the weekend the king of staten
island star's snl co-star bowen yang
opened up to e.t about all the drama
saying pete's castmates are standing
behind him we're just supporting him by
just giving him space i think i think
he's just
you know like
figuring it out because i think a lot is
out of his control maybe in terms of
like people's response and i think he's
just like getting back to his comforts
and i think that's like the best thing
you can do so i think we're all thinking
about him and we love him so
[Music]
much you